one second guys
all right
what's up people oh man
okay turn my mouse around
all right everybody doing oh man
how's everybody doing move our starting
soon sign out of the way poof
man I'm putting my Cape down
yeah that's exactly it oh man this man
has good handwriting that would be a
hilarious troll just put a sign that
just says starting soon and just leave
it there for like eight hours people
would be pissed
let's go oh man
how you guys doing how you guys doing
today uh how does the audio sound is the
audio good cuz I've actually got a
microphone right up here and I feel like
I might need to adjust it a smidge ho
it's like you might hear it there we go
any time Donnie Cates is gonna be on
Thor and that guy's running everything
the Starbucks board we talked about nice
shirt does it come in black yes you can
actually get this shirt hold on a second
hey Rob cor we know comics pretty crazy
oh man
oh what's up guys
let's see
hmm
crazy
hmm okay hmm
let's get our chosen focus let's get
going
yeah we're getting tons of people in
here the audio is good okay I'm glad I
was actually have this curtain behind me
this this sound-dampening curtain behind
me before it was it was really really
echoey yeah we just started basically we
just we just kicked everything
everything in okay so you guys are
probably wondering what's going on with
the idea of a podcast like what's what's
the whole notion behind this your new
podcast set up plus a Q&A session and I
probably should put some more
soundproofing over on this side so that
I kind of get it all just sort of
covered I could just totally cover it
totally immerse myself in it but as you
guys can tell behind me this is uh this
is basically the bar area of my house
those are guys who have seen I've seen
the house tour that I have on my
personal channel there's been a lot of
things going on behind the scenes right
all kinds of things going on behind the
scenes and don't worry guys we will turn
this new a Q&A session how will answer
your questions don't worry I'm not gonna
leave you guys hanging so don't worry
don't worry but we are I mean we can we
can is the audio a little quiet for you
guys that's what is what kind of testing
this out is to see how the sounds and
and I sound a little low on the volume
okay that's really the whole point of
this is to test this out and to see
let's say you make ourselves louder
alright mmm let me all this sounds a
little better for you guys it might be a
little a little too loud all the way to
turn the standard smidge but let's see
okay so so a lot of things be going on
behind the scenes um a lot of you guys
know that I have a personal channel and
and on this personal channel one of the
things that I've been focusing on is is
a series called becoming the rock right
the idea of spiritually and
philosophically and then of course
physically bulking up and losing weight
and so on becoming the rock and and the
idea behind this was was to sort of see
if I could make it work right and so I
might on the the personal channel
obviously though the way this works out
right now at least the way it'll be
going forward its Mondays will be the
according to Rob videos right videos
where I basically talk to you guys about
all kinds of life stuff and different
things like that
Wednesday's will basically be days where
I really kind of chill with you guys to
be honest with you guys
oh we basically sort of relaxed that
sounds better okay it sounds a whole lot
better to you guys I sound perfect now
all right Audio is good okay cool I kind
of figure that all of us who's always
really gonna take is just you know sort
of turning it up a bit and and just kind
of going from there sound quality is
good awesome that's sexy voice hold on
the second Donnie case is gonna be on
Thor and yeah Hickman's on xmitter but
Donnie case is gonna be on Thor Wow
that's gonna be kind of that's gonna be
kind of bonkers god I am getting I'm
getting so sidetracked I'm gonna slide
wreck okay so the idea is is that Monday
in my little notebook is upstairs I had
all this into myself Monday is is the
day where I do according to Rob right
Friday is is where I do becoming the
rock but I'd like basically make a video
addressing the know should address in
the idea of becoming the rock really
that the big thing like Instagram for
example there's something that I'm
really pushing I like make sure you guys
check out my personal Instagram I am Rob
Jefferson that's where I I do live
streams and I hang out and talk to you
guys right because we don't do the Q&A
sessions on a nice explained all that
often but on on on Instagram I live
stream every Monday Wednesday and Friday
well I jump onto on the Instagram and
livestream to you guys every Monday
Wednesday and Friday
today to get a chance to do it because
it's been so exceedingly busy and I
might actually do it after this but but
but Monday Wednesday and Friday is when
I livestream and I and I talk to you
guys which I really dig which I really
enjoy doing
um and then yeah so Wednesday is
actually gonna be the podcast and that's
really what I wanted one of the things I
want to talk about here this notion of
launching a podcast the the podcast that
I want to launch is is part of it I want
to I'm gonna deal with comics but I
don't want to talk all be colleagues
right in weather reasons why is because
when it comes to the comic book
landscape it won't last forever right so
I don't want to be so totally immersed
in comics that when the comic book seems
sort of begins to fade away did I fade
away with it and said I wanna be able to
branch out and talk about other things
right so the first half an hour we'll
deal with comics right so so we'll have
a half
the podcast we talk about comic book
related things right metal that'll
become more clear once I actually launch
it and then for the 15 minutes following
that we're gonna have a discussion of
source on gaming and then we're gonna
wrap it all up with basically a tech
based discussion and that'll be the
hour-long podcast and lets me hit
various different discussions and and I
like that I like the idea I like the
concept of doing that so on the personal
channel it'll be Monday according to Rob
where I just talked to you guys about
life things Wednesday will be the
podcast and then Friday will basically
be me doing an according to I'm sorry
becoming the rock video where I
basically make kind of a discussion type
video recapping everything that's
happened over the last week and the
reason why is because the idea behind
the personal yeah kind of a nerd caste
exactly you know hitting eating a geek
culture for the most part and the
biggest reason why paint being on paint
can already was really fun but but one
of the big reasons why is because the
entire base is the entire theme behind
the personal channel that I run is
finding the light at the end of the
tunnel right you know you me everybody
struggles with with things you know
social awkwardness we struggled with
with wanting to ask out a girl and being
rejected we struggle with one and asked
got a guy and being rejected right
because I've got some female fans in
here you know we started with all kinds
of different things and the idea is to
kind of impart my life experience to you
guys and hope you guys get past those
various things to help you reach the
light at the end of the tunnel right to
reach a better place so having said that
that's that's really kind of the big
thing make sure you guys go check out my
personal Instagram at I am Rob Jefferson
if you guys want to talk to me more
often you guys want to wanted me to do
like a you know want to interact with me
and get your questions answered more
often especially if you're somebody here
who doesn't get a chance to to get yet
you know get your question answered my
my personal hamster gamma is a really
good place to have that done right and
sometimes I bring you guys into the end
of the stream so I talk to you directly
and everybody else just sort of watches
the conversation unfolding you guys in
and like talking directly to you guys in
a conversation it's pretty fun face to
face so this big were as close as we can
get you know cuz they're in there we're
not right now we're not right next to
each other but okay so getting in your
old questions right so the Q&A session
the questions are a ton of questions
everybody everybody's asking all kinds
of different things it's just been it's
it's been been kind
crazy the thing versus the whole okay
they fought a lot over the years and I
would say the Incredible Hulk would win
because the strength is infinite man God
versus the immortal Hulk that's a really
good question okay how many of you guys
are familiar with Man GOG how many of
you guys know who man god is if you know
who man GOG is just type yes and if you
don't just say no and depending on who
all and on how you guys respondent will
go accordingly um but I would say man
God hands down I would say man God like
even the Incredible Hulk is a Herald of
Galactus I would say man GOG because
he's just that powerful it's kind of
nuts um why do you answer it Instagram
through my live streams because the
problem was as soon as I since I hit you
guys hop and I answer as many questions
as I can because the the first day I
told people that I had a personal
Hamsterdam within like two hours it was
99 plus some messages it was just a ton
of messages and it was so unruly the
only way to really answer your all
questions on Instagram was to livestream
to you guys right it was the most most
effective way to answer the question you
guys had to do in a really really fast
pace so it's not that I'm ignoring you
um it's just that there's I get so many
questions coming in as a personal
message on Instagram but I can't
possibly answer them all in a reasonable
mount of time so I I live stream no okay
so so man gog is basically this being
and and its origin is really kind of
murky there's just sort of a thing where
he was there one day but the way it
played out if you go and you read the
old journey journey into mystery comics
um the old written emissaries stories
man God was basically the the last
member are really just kind of like this
amalgamation of all this races hate that
was wiped out by Odin and so is
literally a being a being of like pure
hatred and rage is literally all it is
and it's one of the only things that
Odin is afraid of right I mean when man
God comes callin to Asgard all hell's
gonna break loose it's basically the end
times right that's really what that is
like things are getting ready to pop off
and it's all getting ready to come to an
end but it's it's it's kind of bonkers
um I actually don't have super chat
enabled on here at the moment instead I
wanted to try to try to answer your also
questions as much as I could I do enjoy
the idea of a super chat the fact that
some of you guys can particularly have
your questions answered it can just be
kind of difficult two times because
super chats of because of the fact that
people are paying of course you know I
give those questions precedent but it
means that some of you guys who want
pain in the
I don't really like that you know and so
that's one reasons why in the past when
I did super Chad I would answer a whole
bunch of super chats and then I would
say okay we're gonna stop with those for
a second and answer a bunch of your
all's questions and we'll go back to
doing that you know we'll go back to
enabling super chef but um again if you
guys want to talk to me more frequently
make sure you guys check out my
Instagram at I am Rob Jefferson um man
dog is Kratos man it was long for those
days when you could answer all questions
yeah when I did live streams in like 20
people showed up because my channel was
brand new in some ways I come along for
that too yeah I kind of miss the days
when it was a lot simpler but the cool
thing about it this is one of the best
parts of the best parts of being a
youtuber the coolest thing about being a
youtuber is being able to go places and
meet you guys oh I love meeting you guys
there was one guy I think his name was
David it was like David or Mike I think
I was actually sitting in a car with my
stepmom we were driving out to Logan's
to meet Mariah and my sister for lunch
when when my visited Lexington and I was
always sitting there with the window
down and I was talking to my stepmom and
then I hear this guy he's like yo Rob
but I'm like what the hell and I look
over he's like Rob cor this guy's like
two car lanes over
and it's stuff like that but I love
meeting you guys you guys are awesome
right so yes it's it's one of the best
parts of being being a youtuber so any
thoughts on DC's tales from the dark
multiverse stories I'm actually really
looking forward to that I feel like it's
gonna be tales from the Lantern Corps by
Jeff Johnson who's writing Green Lantern
which we are gonna get back into but I
feel like it'll be on a much bigger
scale right I'm really looking forward
to seeing what all we have to offer at
the end of the day though you know like
any other comic book story that's out
there it really comes down to how it's
being written and and I think it's Scott
Snyder who's doing it I'm not a hundred
percent sure who was this the writing
and our team for it but if the stories
are in terrible of course I'm gonna lose
interest in it but if the stories are
written really really well
then I'm really it would be really
fascinating and I'm really exciting to
see what happens who are the
Thunderbolts the Thunderbolts are a team
that were assembled during the events of
civil war and the idea was to basically
take the villains and then use them as a
means to basically go find superheroes
because Thunderbolts proved to be so
popular during the events of Civil War
and it may have been formed before them
but because Thunderbolts proved to be so
popular during the events of civil war
Marvel kept it going the issue is that
after Civil War
it kind of waxed and waned a little bit
and I really think the team peaked when
you had Red Hulk and Deadpool and
Elektra and one or two other people I
can truth a were and then just kind of
dropped off after that that's what a
lost interest after that but basically
think of think of the Thunderbolts is
like the Legion of Doom from DC Comics
except sometimes or good guys and that's
that's really kind of it the original
team was led by led by Baron Helmut by
yeah Helmut Zebo Hellmann's emo who was
it that led the original look read the
live the first Thunderbolts um yeah
Baron Helmut Zemo yeah so let's see can
I explain who dark hawk is um I may do
that dark Explorer those characters
where I would make a video explaining
the character if there was a reason to
like if an announcement was made but for
the most part it doesn't really seem to
involve anything going on at the moment
so there really doesn't really seem to
be a reason to unless I'm missing
something
so she McGrath definitely I see you type
in shoot McGrath a very very powerful
character it's it's kind of nuts let's
see hey Rob is there any advice on how
to get started doing YouTube make your
videos be consistent upload a video
every day be consistent make your videos
over ten minutes and use Google Trends
as a means to search for topics that
people are looking for so uh let's see
let's see strangers randomly scream your
name in public
hilarious yet telling you the same let's
see do I think the comic industry will
die in the near future absolutely not
comics are always gonna be popular even
if they go back to being a niche thing
like color book movies basically drop
off in popularity even if they go back
to being a niche thing they're always
gonna be popular comic books are always
gonna be a huge thing so that's that's
not really gonna change if that's always
gonna be a concept or a big deal so
Christian Bale is live-action Batman
Batman who laughs thoughts I don't
really see it happening I think I'd have
to grab somebody else Christian Bale
doesn't really have because what you
would need is somebody who could play
the Joker right like that's what you
would need Christian no not Christian
Bale um if Heath Ledger was alive like
Heath Ledger is a bad man who last would
be insanely amazing but you know you
need someone who can play the Joker
because all the really all the Batman
who laughs is is the Joker with the
intelligence of Batman that's really all
it is you know and so you it's really
more Joker than Batman
personality that's really what you need
so let's see what are my thoughts on
chip sidarskys daredevil I haven't read
it but you guys have been screaming at
me and telling me it's amazing so I
guess I should but I mean I hit up Sal
before New Yorker hits I'll hit Mia
before New York when he found out I
wasn't going and weird we were we were
we were kind of you know we were going
back and forth about a lot of the comics
that were out talking about spider-man
different things like that he said chip
sidarskys daredevil is amazing so if
it's really that good they don't have to
check it out I have to take a look at it
um let's see I don't know why that's
helpful review um Legion of super-heroes
vs. x-men x-men but only because I'm
biased because I like the x-men more
because I'm an x-men fan through and
through and that's just the way it is
speaking which I'm in to ask you guys
what do you guys think about this
backdrop what do you guys think about
this background here the ones light in
the back in the bar area by the way that
that picture right there
that's spider-man by Alex Ross so and
actually back there behind the curtain
is a picture of the Incredible Hulk by
electro so so but let me know you guys
think about that oh man a Jeff Johnson
hickman team-up would be insane I would
dig that the fulcrum versus to be honest
well that's the thing we don't know a
whole lot about the fulcrum right the
fulcrum just showed up during the events
of Neil Gaiman's Sandman and it's
alluded to that the fulcrum is basically
the one above all but we don't know if
the fulcrum is the one above all then
the B honors are done like that
if the fulcrum is just a really powerful
entity basically anybody but the one
above all then the beyonders one and
that's really one that's really what it
comes down to it looks nice you love it
I like it
oh man okay how do you want Wolverine to
be introduced into the MCU and do I
think Hickman should help write the MCU
movies um okay here's the thing with
Hickman
I think Hickman would be better instead
of writing a singular movie I think
Hickman would be better at like planning
movies right because Hickman is one of
the big things about Hickman love it or
hate it and it's something that I love
Hickman is really good with the slow
burn right he's really good at telling a
story that takes five years to flesh out
it takes five years to finish
Hickman is incredibly good
that writing really short stories that
that that that kind of begin an end
Hickman is okay with that way but I
think he's better with like long-form
stories where you have some room to flex
his writing muscles and he can kind of
you know sort of let loose and let
things kind of go after a little while
so I think Hickman writing like like
planning out the x-men in the MC was a
really really good idea
having said that but the way that I
would introduce Wolverine is I would say
that after the events captain a man I'm
sorry that captain where after the
events of Avengers in game and infinity
war which I'll have a video on this by
the way after the events of Avengers in
game and infinity war with Sam Wilson
becoming the new Captain America well
for the most parts that's accepted
Sam Wilson has no Super Soldier Serum
and what America wants is a super
soldier Layton so they basically try to
duplicate the serum of Abraham Erskine
which nobody can do because one he's
been gone for seventy years and two he
died you know seventy years ago and so
the one thing I end up doing is taking
like a handful of different people and
basically trying to experiment on them
more or less they end up finding James
Howlett who's part of Team X this kind
of black ops wet work team team that
takes out performs all kinds of
different tasks they bring him in they
discover that he has a mutant gene or at
least some kind of extra gene that when
activated give people powers essentially
the Ultimate Universe origin of the
x-men and then you end up having
Wolverine going forward and then you
know that the thing is synthesized and
mutants everywhere except waking up
across the world or something like that
who is the strongest spider-man it is
spider-man from Earth 13 I think it is
the version of Peter Parker who never
lost the who never lost the Enigma force
after his battle with the Trice and melt
I think it was which is kind of cool
let's see
well him Dafoe was the Batman who lost
there you go that's a really good call
he could be really really dark so he
could he could be really really solid do
I write a script for my videos sometimes
I do if it's a video like Beyond
omega-level yes usually I'll write a
script on that um if it is a video where
I'm just running over a comic or I'm
explaining a character know like if I'm
doing like magneto explained it's not a
script it's all off top my head all the
stuff that I know sometimes I might have
to do research depending on how in-depth
I want to go but for the most part it's
just stuff that I know
so let's see what are my predictions for
Dawn of X it's gonna take about three
years to finish that's my prediction on
no I don't even think so because three
years you're talking about 36 issues
right so uh Hickman you're probably into
writing it for five to eight years I
think ah but honestly I don't really
know I mean I we won't know until the
until this is coming Wednesday with the
end of powers of X that's what we'll
really find out what to expect going
into like Dawn of X and all that kind of
stuff so let's see what am i mixed with
I'm part black and part light can I
please say what up Home Slice
what up Home Slice would it be like does
the new Joker to thrown in game uh no I
don't think it D Thrones in game because
you're talking about two different types
of movies and those spoilers I'm not
gonna spoil anything but uh but you talk
about two different types of movies that
the Joker is a solo film that focuses on
a particular character right and like
the evolution of that character and how
they became who they are and different
things like that what goes into the
mindset and so on and so forth a
vendor's indie game was ensemble film
right it was just a great big huge
battle you know a great shooter conflict
so you're talking about two different
types of films well you know it's like
asking if you know Indiana Jones a movie
about a movie about the Indiana Jones is
better than like Lord of the Rings so
you know I mean it's it's they're both
in the realm of fantasy but at the end
of the day like you know you're talking
about how long Sabo film versus a solo
film more or less with the supporting
cast so what do I think of house of X I
love house of X absolutely adore house
of X I think it's good to see the x-men
basically getting their return right
after the events of all-new
all-different marvel the x-men have kind
of been screwed over really really bad
right you know Marvel was really pushing
the Inhumans from what I understand it
was editorial mandate but Marvel was
really pushing in humans because of the
fact that the you know Fox wouldn't give
them back and so model is being kind of
pissy about it nobody wanted the
Inhumans the Inhumans suck they've
always sucked like they've never been
interesting I mean they've got
interesting stories but the Inhumans
themselves were never interesting or
intriguing it's the reason why you know
they weren't really well received by
fans and the result was that you know
the x-men people were kind of pissed off
about that but now Marvel's probably
bringing the x-men back to prominence
and Hickman's man to do it you know so
I'm really enjoying really enjoying that
so
let's see her the MCU potential let's
see the interview potentially start
singer war soon not soon I would say
they're gonna do secret words you're
talking about five to ten years from now
you talk about a little while from now
we're I'd like building up to it if I
were then if I were the Marvel Cinematic
Universe honestly I would focus on
Galactus I'd focus on Silver Surfer and
then I would focus on the Nile ation
it's like the next big event right
that's what I would focus on and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe DC store
Marvel Zombies Marvel Zombies but only
because it was more fleshed out if
decease went on longer and they expanded
that universe more then honestly they
probably about even I mean you're
talking about Robert Kirkman writing
Marvel Zombies vs Tom Taylor writing
deceased I would say probably you know
they'd be pretty even in terms of in
terms of how it goes what kind of music
do I listen to
um I love EDM I love electronic dance
music I have since I first heard the
State of Trance a year mix in 2004 and
then after that it was in search of
sunrise and I got into Paul Oakenfold
and then I got into more TSO stuff and
then discovered like cascade and
different things like that um I also
loved a loaf I hip-hop absolutely love
loaf why you know it's really good to
relax too if I'm taking a bath and I
just want to like relax I'll listen a
low funny hip-hop if I'm editing photos
you know for for Instagram I'll listen
to look like hip-hop uh I like rock
music so like 80s rock here band rock
basically you know I enjoy almost all
kind of music except for like hee haw
gospel gospel quartet country music kind
of stuff not really into that too much I
wasn't I was younger but not so much now
let's see uh whatever Rob how do you get
started with with weight loss well I'm
really good what I ended up doing and it
actually works for me is I went online
looked at a calculator to see how many
calories I was supposed to eat and then
I would eat that many calories and I
would measure my weight every day for
about about two or three weeks and I
would see how much of a change there was
if I was losing weight then I would kind
of start incrementing increasing my
calories by about a hundred calories a
day until my way stayed constant then I
would know that's how many calories I
need to eat and then eat less than that
that's basically what it is unless
you're lifting weights and then of
course you have to compensate for the
way you want to put on and building
muscle which means any more calories or
than any more Pro
so um thoughts on fat Thor absolutely
loved fat boy um I don't really watch
anime too much Mariah got me to watch
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood which
is enjoyable but I would go back and
watch it again and then she got me to
watch Avatar The Last Airbender from
season two I think to the end of the
show and again now it was okay I
probably wouldn't watch it again never
really was a huge fan of anime outside
of Dragon Ball Z it was just never
really something that I got into so um
let's see who do I think would win win
in death battle Inhumans and the x-men
the x-men they're just all there's more
of them and they're more powerful so I
would definitely say the x-men let's see
I'm gonna buy this is hell for review oh
because it's got a curse word ad it's
like samurai shampoo whatever that
happens to be oh do I go to the gym to
don't have a gym in my garage I've got
all of my weights and everything all in
my garage so um let's see but I never
get contacts actually I considered LASIK
surgery and basically removing the need
for glasses I'm still toying around with
the idea not a hundred percent sure I'm
comfortable with surgery being performed
on my eyes before well I understand it's
basically foolproof now but I don't want
to be that one that you know 99.9% I
don't want to be that 0.01 percent where
things go bad and I'm basically blind
for the rest of my life you know I don't
want to be that guy
let's see ever play Borderlands love
Borderlands Borderlands 2 was was it was
is the only one well Borderlands 2 and
then boy lands the pre-sequel which
sucked but Borderlands 2 was the one
that I played I enjoyed that one never
played borderlands 1 and i have not
played borderlands 3 yet but but I did
enjoy Borderlands 2 absolutely loved it
let's see do I think DC will ever bring
back the image comics um Image Comics is
not part of DC Image Comics is his own
wholly separate brand its own its own
subsidiary right its own thing and
independent comic book house so DC
doesn't really have any involvement in
that so excited to hear about the new
podcast actually explained it at the
beginning of the at the beginning of the
stream so if you if you want to feel
free to go back and watch that and then
when you're finished just hit live on
the screen again and it'll bring you
back to where we
so um let's see am I gonna do a video on
the new official DC's timeline yes and
in fact I'm actually working on
organizing it right now in structuring
and I think a lot of you guys are gonna
dig this because you've been asking for
it for a while I'm actually organizing
and structuring it basically based on
what Scott Snyder's doing with Perpetua
and in the multiverse and all that kind
of stuff I'm gonna do a history of the
DC universe like I did a history of the
Marvel Universe the history the Marvel
Universe was only designed to run up
until the modern day which is to say the
rise of superheroes in the 1960s DC will
be the same way it'll be like the rise
of superheroes um probably you know
going up to crisis on Infinite Earths
that's where it will stop because DC
hasn't really rebooted since then maybe
going up the new 52 you and dr.
Manhattan only because of the watchman's
involvement and everything but but yeah
so um what am i thoughts on a spectrum
movie I don't know if I could watch a
movie about the spectre I think it's a
cool idea but I don't really know if I
would go watch a movie about the wrath
of God you know I heard about the
judgment of God I don't know how to
really get into that too much um what I
want to help write comment books it
funny enough probably not
ah my really one of my big goal is one
of the things I'd love to do is to
basically advise the Marvel Cinematic
Universe on the direction of the x-men
in the MCU be part of that kind of
creative team that basically moves the
x-men you know to where they're gonna be
I would love to do that right because
you know I can say without arrogance I'm
probably in the top 1% if not the top 1%
of the 1% most knowledgeable people on
the planet about the x-men right I've
been reading them for 25 years I'm very
very knowledgeable about the team you
know not to mention all the research and
all the things that I've looked up you
know before I started reading comics you
know about the about the team and so on
so if I'm being honest I think I could
be a pretty huge asset to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and helping to build
the x-men and and and move them in a
forward direction so did we keep the cat
yes we still have a week for the
original owners to claim if those guys
don't know and then we were always
actually talking about this on the on my
vlogging channel that personal vlogging
channel which is odd which is Robert
Jefferson here on YouTube just
youtube.com slash Robert Jefferson make
sure you go check it out and subscribe
but I was talking about that myself a
Mariah Mariah actually has a cooking
stream on Twitch twist TV slash eat
codes where she basically
cooks her way through video game themed
cookbooks and which is a really really
cool idea and she was finishing up her
stream
like a cat ran by the back door and I
was like - there's a Katherine by the
back door so we go - we go to look at it
this little kitten this little itty
bitty kid that looked like it was four
months old
not even not even that old and it was
trying to get into the house and we
caught it and we brought it in we fed it
you know watered it and and kept it for
the night and then the next day Mariah
took it to the Humane Society and said
hey look we found this cat we're not
really sure what to do and they said
well you have 14 days for the original
owners to claim it to basically report
the cat is lost and it wasn't microchips
so we don't know who the owners are now
so they were like you have about 14 days
to claim it and if nobody claims it
after that 14 days then they can't
belongs to you
so we have a week left until that 14
days is over so um let's see one of my
thoughts on Galactus versus man-god or
thunder in Richards versus him uh well
Fran if you're talking about him that
means you're talking about Adam warlock
and Franklin Richards wouldn't demolish
him and Galactus versus man dog I don't
know I don't really see ooh
sorry about that guys
oh man my camera kicked off for some
reason I'm not entirely sure why but
anyway ah man GOG would or yeah Galactus
could destroy man GOG he would just wipe
them out of existence so that wouldn't
really be much of a other contest
between the two so yeah it's my camera
kicked off I'm not really sure why um I
thought I had it set to where he would
never actually go off but we may need to
double check that setting and make sure
hopefully everybody in the world is a
start bailing out so blackout we'll see
what had happened was you guys are
paying respects those guys who don't
know that started on Twitch
there was an MV and yeah everybody
everybody type F everybody in the chat
type F just just type the type of letter
F just do that um the way that started
out was and I didn't really know what
initially until I saw the until I was
watching III or whatever it was and they
were showing the trailer for for the new
god of war which of course is a while
ago and there's one point where like the
Sun gets hit or something like that I
can't member and everybody in the chat
starts typing F and I'm like what in the
heck does that mean if it he's like well
and and one of the Call of Duty games
there's a scene where you can press f to
pay respects and the result was that
like everybody sort of typing F whenever
somebody dies basically it's kind of
what that's a reference to so
everybody's hiding F now so I type F for
here's a funny thing if you type alt f4
it'll automatically exit your screen
it'll automatically kick your screen off
like like close your window so um let's
see hold on sorry there's there's
questions coming in could we possibly
work together in the future
um I mean Sydney an email I mean I can't
guarantee it but but send me an email
I'm a little like I'm a little picky
about who I choose to work with just
because of the fact that in the comic
book lands or at least in the comic book
YouTube landscape right now there's a
lot of people who really look kind of
like to stir up trouble
and cause issues and I try to avoid that
and and one of the things I learned with
with a brief with somebody that I
previously worked with is that once they
make that turn um it can kind of come
back and look bad on me and and
basically end up damaging my brand uh
which is not something that I'm really
looking forward to so so yeah I mean
send me an email that's not to say I
won't work with you but send me an email
and and we'll go from there so no I'm
not like I said I'm not really a huge
fan of manga so um let's see for anime
gotta watch Death Note and code yeah I
heard death notes really really good it
seems kind of weird having some spirit
follow you around and getting you to
kill people it's kind of strange but
let's see what would when should Marvel
insert the stranger cosmic entity in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they give you
that at any point um maybe they could do
that pretty much any point in time
there's there's really no limit to then
being able to pull that off just because
of the fact that that I don't know I
mean it's it's the stranger right they
don't have to explain who he is because
we don't really even know who he is in
the Marvel in more incentives there's
well there's one instance in like the
comment I think with a lemon tribunal is
like this stranger represents like my
fourth face and the strangers like no I
don't either you know it's some of the
one of those lines I I can remember it's
this kind of wild but yeah we kept the
cat we found
did you guys hear the story of keeping
the cat yeah we definitely kept the cat
that we found so let's see uh I should
you house powers of X my email is robbed
at comics explain calm yeah so that's a
really good way to get a hold of me also
again my if you guys are also interested
in working with me and stuff to make
sure you follow my personal Instagram at
I am Rob Jefferson I had live stream you
guys all the time over there so if
you're trying to get a hold of me that's
that's one of the better ways to get a
hold of me
at I am Rob Jefferson and and hit me up
so I ewr NXT aew do that show the other
night was amazing it was a great way to
start their start their first television
television event so let's see do I think
the MCU hit its peak no I don't think so
I mean here's here's the thing you guys
have to remember and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
here's what we have oh here's fufu
cuddly poops here's the kitty you guys
were asking about the kitty here is the
kitty
here is the kitten fufu cuddly poops is
actually what we named her as the name
she's been given so far she's like
please oh that's on onslaught in the MCU
uh I mean I'd love to see onslaught the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but your talk
about it would be a while before we'd be
able to see that happen but it'd be a
while before that took place
have I ever watched legends of tomorrow
i watch the first two seasons didn't
really get into it
apparently I stopped watching before it
got good apparently I got really good
into the third season and that's the
case I need to go back and watch season
three so but no I don't think the MCU is
hit his peak right because here's what
you've seen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
right now here's basically what you've
seen you seen Thanos basically going on
a truck to capture the Infinity Gauntlet
the guardians of the galaxy figured out
what was going on halfway through and
tried to stop him and everybody on the
earth was totally oblivious until he got
there and then they fought Thanos and he
basically wiped out half a life in the
universe and then five years later they
fought him again they went back in time
and they changed everything in one what
you've seen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is basically a six-issue story
arc from Marvel Comics that's it right
there that's basically yet it's the
equivalent of a six-issue story arc with
some time ins right like someone shots
the origin of Thor the origin of Iron
Man the origin of Captain America and
that's basically yeah ah we haven't even
begun to scratch the tip of the iceberg
alright I mean right now with the last
10 years we've seen we're at the tip of
the very very tip of the very very top
of the very point of the of this iceberg
right like it would take I mean honestly
if they decided to make movies about
Marvel comics they could do it for
hundreds of years right I mean there's
just so much to do there's so much to
cover now doesn't mean it would be
successful
no not everything would be good if they
made a made a movie about unas the
untouchable it would flop but but you
know Otis the untouchable by the way was
a guy who had the ability to create a
creative force fields and I want to say
that like either he lost control of his
powers or like Jean Grey shut them off
or something like that and he ended up
suffocating inside his own force field
he was it was it was kind of crappy do
not trust the cat cats are evil
put my my hat my cat in a Hell in a Cell
match against of New York City rat no I
wouldn't either that New York City right
where my counterpart do I think homeland
er could defeat Superman I don't know I
mean he's basically a pastiche to
Superman so as far as I'm concerned
they're equal in power but yes I've seen
the boys on Amazon Prime it's so good
dude the cliffhanger or the first season
was nuts I was like are they for real
like are these guys serious this Katzen
dawned on me like this cat is is chewing
on me you taste delicious human I'd like
to consume more of you put the hand down
what I type a play Mario Kart do I ever
pick Luigi no nobody picks Luigi all
right either you pick a little princess
peach or you pick where you pick a
little Princess Peach basically you pick
the fastest characters right like wha
Luigi's relatively fast
uh yes you're gonna pet my cat come on a
second here pet my kitty cats that might
cut so which is my favorite DC comic of
all time
or or right now at the moment I would
say and I know this is gonna be a sort
of controversial Tom Kings Batman I love
Tom Kings Batman one so let's see I made
the cat doop I'm not maybe I'm not gonna
name the cat dude I'm not naming the cat
after some weird character from the
x-men who was cool but still weird right
like spoke some language that only
Wolverine can understand like I'm not
I'm not gonna do that so cat man
explained am I gonna go see birds of
prey absolutely I'm a decided the idea
of birds of prey I am I am super hyped
about birds of prey I'm looking for free
my cats gonna step on a so I picked
luigi WTF stop kitty you're gonna spill
this water all over the place I know I'm
not gonna make a beep uh let's see have
I seen the uncut gems trailer no oh no
uncut gems yeah the one with Adam
Sandler yeah I saw that during Joker
during the Joker film they show the
trailer from before the Joker movie it
looks amazing like it looks really
really good
imagine if the cat had my morning voice
yeah my morning voice is kind of insane
you guys heard her this morning when I
recorded the Joker movie or the Joker
video there is basically one morning
voice
it's super super deep yeah I might do
that on Instagram record an Instagram
video or do an Instagram livestream when
I first wake up so you guys can hear my
morning voice those guys I don't know my
personal Instagram is at I am rob
Jefferson go check it out and and follow
me over there King for number one have
it ready yet I actually need to I'm kind
of behind on Marvel to be honest like
it's sort of painful like I would I'm
behind on like invincible I am an and
behind a lot of stuff I think it caught
up with Marvel comics so let's see have
I have you played Marvel Ultimate
Alliance yes I love ultimate along I've
not played Ultimate Alliance 3
I've played Ultimate Alliance 1 & 2 I
loved Ultimate Alliance how many of you
guys like Ultimate Alliance like how
many guys dug that that was there was it
was really really good so let's see who
would I pick right now to play a Norman
Osborn in the MCU if it wasn't so old
Tommy Lee Jones but a play right now I
don't know I have to think I'd have to
have to look up actors to really get a
feel for who I think she'd be able to
play yeah do I collect comics in
physical or digital format I get comics
in in physical format only if they're
significant only if they're really
important to me right like I've got a
copy of giant-size x-men number one that
I had signed by Jonathan Hickman he made
out to me right like it was a craziest
thing we were to San Diego Comic Con
myself more I were and I got giant-sized
actually number one and I got it signed
by hitman like I'm standing there in
line I presented to him he's like hey
you're the comics explained guy I was
like yeah man and he's like dude awesome
so so he and I were talking and I was
like dude I'm so hyped rewriting the
x-men I love everything that you do what
are your plans were news tell me what
his plans were like what do you wanted
to do with everything and and what
direction it's all supposed to go in
which I can't tell you but but it was
cool because I was like we'll do can you
sign this for when he's like dude is
this real and I was like yeah man and I
needs like I mean you owe me I was like
dude make it out to me man I'm never
gonna sell this and do you is he's
excited here's the thing comic book
writers are they get really really
excited if you if you have a comic made
out to yourself if you have them make it
up to you instead of just autographing
it because they think you're gonna sell
it but if you if you've made out to you
well then it's your comic right there's
this like okay this guy wants it because
he really enjoys my work not because
he's trying to profit off of my work
which I love what hitman does
so so yeah I had a signed by signed by
him so have I played Marvel contest of
Champions I played it when it first came
out and I read the kind of book when it
first came out but uh but no I haven't
really played it since so let's see
Ultimate Alliance that's that's the
other one I was trying to think of was
ultimately was yeah Ultimate Alliance
yeah Ultimate Alliance was really good
too so see how should they bring this
entry into the MCU the same way they do
Wolverine except to say it's a century
instead I mean they could kind of do it
like he's been on ice for a while or
something like that but honestly I
wouldn't bring the the century into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe of the moment
I really wouldn't do that you know I
think that there's better characters to
bring in besides him so it'd be kind of
funny though if they did the century and
then did it really really well
because then people would be like okay
so mama can do a better Superman than
Warner Brothers people we got people be
pissed about that but uh yes I'm
enjoying deceased absolutely loved DC's
let's see who's my favorite and least
favorite x-man ooh what a good question
um my favorite x-man well he's not
really an x-man but he is a mutant it's
definitely apocalypse my least favorite
probably mystique I've never really
found mystique to be interesting like I
never really found her to be intriguing
she's okay but I never really found her
to be that that that's spectacular
so any low fly recommendations ooh
definitely new jobbies is a really good
one and then new oh jeez is a really
really good one in you a Jes I think is
how you pronounce it
those are those are two really really
good low fly hip hop artists so let's
see do I think the MC will introduce the
elders of the universe let me they
already have they introduced well
actually you know after that question
for me guys who's your favorite who's
your favorite x-man like like who's your
favorite member of the x-men team or
your favorite mutants you don't have to
be an x-men but who's your favorite
member of the x-men so keep in mind
Deadpool has been an x-man - so um but
uh I forgot what I was gonna say I've
never seen Joe Joe
I've never seen jojoba JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure so um did I start with the
x-men animated series yes it was
actually the x-men animated series that
got me into comics so I definitely
started with like a lot of people I
started with a TV show so Cyclops is the
best I have not sort of flashed forward
so who's my favorite Robin
yours is djaro Oh mine's definitely
mine's definitely Damian Wayne because I
like the progression of Damian's
character I like how his characters
grown and changed over the years so
Scarlet Witch magic gambit Wolverine for
but favorite x-man is Magneto that's a
good choice that's a good pick Gabriel
summers that's a really good pick to
volcán is definitely one of the cooler
characters out there everybody in the
world is typing responses the Chad just
exploded with responses old man Logan is
a good one old man Logan is a really
good one uh let's see gambit the Frank
was Richards man yeah gambit if he's
done right that's definitely true if
he's done right that's that's definitely
a solid one yeah nineties x-men was
really really good though the show was
96 been comics for a pain they were a
hassle to try to try to read and
understand it was it was sort of nuts
like 90s comics where we're rough the
dude throws cards and it was pretty cool
it is it is a pretty awesome power to
have ah let's see the memes are getting
late yeah no super chat options I kind
of won to stick to not super chat just
sort of answer a lot of the questions
you guys kind of the next Q&A we do
we'll bring it back but I just kind of
wanted to to focus on you guys as
opposed to you know doing super chats
could've been a while since we've done
this so but again if you guys aren't
interested in talking to me more
frequently in like live streams or being
in my live streams check me out at I am
Rob Jefferson on Instagram and and I'll
incorporate you guys into my live
streams different things like that so I
actually bring you guys into the streams
and talk to you all directly which is
really cool we're just really really
enjoyable crash against me
and be broken dude apocalypse had the
best one-liners that x-men the animated
series okay here's the question that I
have for you guys because I asked this
in a previous stream here's a
for you guys all right and and be honest
here be honest here all right if you if
you if you cut the books all no but if
you fib
oh well no um say that you're stuck on a
desert island and you only get to watch
one TV show for the rest of your life
which TV show do you pick Batman the
Animated Series or the original Teen
Titans which one do you pick I want to
know I want to see what you guys say I
want to see what what do you guys say so
uh
Channing Tatum will not be gay but no he
won't like Channing Tatum was never
gonna be gambit anybody who ever
believed that yeah Matt Hobbs that movie
was gonna be made no that was that was
never gonna happen so um let's see Darth
Vader vs magneto Darth Vader that's not
even a question so secret six explained
only because Cat Man isn't it Rob
noticin all right I'll have to go no cat
man's a guy from from the Justice
Society of America right the guy dressed
as the black cat
Batman T is lost that's Batman Batman
everybody say in Batman everybody saying
Batman the Animated Series there's some
original Teen Titans but everybody's
saying Batman
everybody's saying Batman the Animated
Series oh man oh well the secret six
show did not go forward that kind of
sucks so Teen Titans is longer yeah it
does go on longer so but it is Batman
the Animated Series though the first
season had like a million episodes there
was insane it had like a hundred and a
hundred thousand episodes it was crazy
okay I'm gonna turn this Q&A session on
you guys right because I like asking you
guys questions cuz I like hearing your
all's answers okay which version of
Flash is your favorite if somebody asked
me right like Alex asked me my favorite
is Barry which version of the flash is
your favorite is it Barry is it Wally is
it is it well we get you could choose
any of the speedsters right so you could
choose like Barry Wally impulse if you
wanted to ah
which version which which flash is your
favorite which flash do you like the
most
so yes I'm very excited for birds of
prey I'm very very hyped for birds of
prey so let's see Kitty is sleeping yeah
kitty kitty is sound asleep
the kid is sleeping thank yo this cat
this cat earlier today me more I could
figure it out we were like what are you
on like this
that was what flying around the damn
house and everything you're really gonna
take sugar or something like that you're
like what is your deal kitty
what is your problem kitty berry classic
wall us that's a good point
that's a no I'm sorry that's a good
choice earth to flash Jay Garrick yeah
Jay Garrick is easy original that's a
good choice Barry Allen Ray Allen Barry
all the way huh
Barry bow all of its like a lot of
people really seem to be flashy like
seem to be fans of Barry Allen Wally
West okay we're getting a lot of Wally
West now we're getting a lot of Wally
West responses Flash Gordon flash
[Music]
accelerated man okay what's another good
question okay which one do you guys like
better Batman or moon night
let's see what those responses are
Johnny Thunder Johnny Thunder is a good
choice so you think birds of prey looks
bad no I think birds of prey looks fun
that's nests see that's one of the
things that I think is the most
important right it's not a matter of
whether or not the movies like
blockbuster and and like like
oscar-worthy or anything like that right
like Marvel's got they're really serious
films for the last play what I like are
the films that are fun right like the
Marvel Cinematic Universe films are
great films but I also like the fun film
that's why she Sam was so amazing Shazam
was like what if a kid became Superman
right I was like dude I remember being a
kid and wishing I was Superman and I
would have done that I would have gone
to the store and bought like nudie
magazines and beer now here would have
been awesome but but now it was it was
it was you know it looks good like it
looks fun let's just give me an
enjoyable movie so I'm definitely
looking forward to it
Batman Batman Batman Batman lots of
Batman what was this question who's my
favorite youtuber that I'm not friends
with ooh that's a good question
probably Peter McKinnon I'm a huge fan
his YouTube channel I'd love to spend
like a day with that guy and and he's
just like like he'll just teach me
everything he knows about like how to
shoot really good videos how does she
like b-roll I would love that right
shoot me roll and take pictures I don't
have spend a day with that guy and and
that would be a lot of you like dude
I'll fly to Canada because I think he's
in Toronto I was like oh I'll fly to
Toronto and for like a day and you just
teach me everything you know and then I
will put it to use and I will go back
home I would love to do that that would
be amazing
so I found your lost cat Miller malar to
you if you guys have a question just
type it and I'll get to it as best I can
but again if I don't get to your
questions here if you follow me at I am
rob Jefferson on Instagram I'm probably
I'll probably answer your question there
though you probably seen a better chance
of getting an answer there so it's also
I'm white burn
I've loved white burn how many of you
guys us have seen bright burn answer
that question for me how many of you
guys have seen it I loved bright burn I
think right burn has incredible
potential with building up like a dark
superhero mc- to be here like like earth
3 basically giving us like earth 3:03
sorry earth 3 characters I think it'd be
awesome like I love that idea
asked century or Superman how do i
balance Marvel vs. DC honestly I don't
really worry about Wall reverses DC I
just read whatever stories are
interesting to me the whole notion of
like who's better Marvel vs. DC I lost
interest in that 20 years ago I mean it
was really mad at me too much anymore
now it's just do I like this story right
and it's because it's the nature of the
industry that sometimes like some some
publishers like Marvel to do really
really well
and DC will do bad and DC will do well
and mama will do bad and sometimes they
both do well and sometimes they both do
bad
they both did bad in the 1990s ah and
they both did well in the mid-2000s so
it depends on on which one you enjoy so
it's really just you know what kind of
character you're like I'm sorry what
kind of publisher you like so
Bradburn was dope it was definitely dope
it was a great movie
where should I start with Constantine
Hellblazer I like Doctor Strange and I
love Neil Gaiman's take on Sandman so I
get help laser recommendations to me
recommended to me a lot um honestly if
you want to look if you want to read
Hellblazer it depends on how far back
you want to go if you want to be John
Constantine who ages in real time go
read the original Constantine run if all
you want is what's going on right now
just read the Constantine rebirth and
then just go for I guess the Hellblazer
rebirth and go forward from there that's
really all you need so that's that's
kind of the benefit of Marvel's I'm
sorry of DC's a magic side is this not
like Marvel with Doctor Strange well I
mean you and Marlowe Doctor Strange it's
kind of like that but DC's is so far
removed from the rest of the superhero
landscape that it's really its own thing
right might as well be its own imprint
which you know you used to be vertigo
and now it's not now it's it's DC so
favorite Green Lantern um my favorite
Green Lantern is probably guy guard I'm
sorry Jon Stewart who's your favorite
Green Lantern after that question for me
let's see uh well we ever get a chance
to rob for brains again okay so here's
the deal with rob for rings and I'm
trying to figure this out um right now
on patreon I had it set up and it was
the only real amicable way that I could
think of doing it and then keep like the
demand low I'm not super high that I
would sell out and immediately right
because if I just if I'd made a youtube
video right now and I said hey guys rob
port razor for sale go to this place and
by them unless they have like an insane
supply they would be sold out in the
blink of an eyelid I wouldn't be able to
keep up with demand and so so because
then I was trying to find a way to kind
of make it work and on patreon if you
paid 20 bucks a month there was like a
lottery system but the more I thought
about that the more was kinda like
that's not really really a cool thing so
what I might do is is well I might
remove it from patreon and I might go
ahead and say all those people right now
who have been paying like 20 bucks a
month for a chance to get one they all
get it are they they all basically get a
payout for it and then what I'll
probably do is just do like short sales
and just say okay guys for you know I
have like a hundred rockport rings for
sale the the first hundred people to
send me an email get it and then like
you know like sue me how much money I'm
on PayPal and then I'll send it off to
you right like once the PayPal
transaction is complete then like it'll
be emailed to you or I'm sorry be be
mailed to you I might do that
I think that's a more reasonable way to
do it so that a lot of people can get
them at the same time kind of keep the
numbers low I think I might do that
so it seems like it would be a better
alternative still like 22 time we're
like 50 at a time or something along
those lines so um let's see uh will I
cover Darth Vader comics I've thought
about that I'm not a hundred son sure I
know Karen Gillan's Darth Vader was
amazing there was what was that what was
that one that there's this one point
we're like the Rebel Alliance catches up
to Darth Vader and they're like look
there's nowhere you can go you're
surrounded and he's like all I'm
surrounded by his fear and dead men it
was pretty amazing like it was it was
one of the most ball and things I've
ever seen it was pretty badass so I
didn't really watch the Constantine TV
show and judging by the fact that was
canceled don't really think most people
watched it so let's see okay well guys
we've been doing this for about an hour
or so so I'm gonna go ahead and bounce
off or I'm gonna go ahead and wrap this
up I do want to say thank you to
everybody for coming out make sure you
guys go follow my instagram at I am
Roberson i livestream there every Monday
Wednesday and Friday I bring you guys
into my streams so I talk to you
directly and it's a it's a way for you
to get your questions answered or to
interact with me more frequently than
how I do on here web so make sure you
guys go check that out and and yeah so
make sure you guys go check out my
vlogging channel the podcast will be up
every Wednesday and then of course I'll
have my own videos they come out every
Monday and every Friday so Monday
Wednesday and Friday we have videos
going up on that channel at the
really gonna enjoy it there's a pretty
big backlog backlog of videos about 200
videos are already there I think you
guys would really enjoy it you guys
would love to go check it out
or we're definitely loved if you checked
it out so yeah um go take a look at
everything and and yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and bounce off here guys thank you
for coming out it was awesome talking to
you all and I will catch you all later
peace